et vous
[Musique]
depuis vendredi les revendications n'ont
pas changé d'équipement manque de moyens
financiers des demandes jusque là
restées lettre morte
et si mal an men en fait pour moi ma
fille a plu à dimanche et c'est pas
normal top les examens finaux peuvent
aller masser ou ceux et celles qui font
passer des métiers ccf
le propos est facile donc tout cela
c'est contradictoire avec la
l'enseignement confessionnel radio que
mon défi non c'est beaucoup d'heures est
le premier moteur dans les toilettes
s'est passé parfois s'est pas adapté
pour venir
donc voilà il ya beaucoup ya beaucoup de
difficultés nous avons décidé de nous
mobiliser pour pouvoir monter un petit
peu au peuple ce qui se passe dans la
liste et là nous avons besoin de
l'équipe de tout le monde les élèves du
lycée professionnel agricole du robert
soutenus par leurs professeurs
nous sommes dans le besoin nous n'avons
pas les moyens de travailler les élèves
je suis prof de génie alimentaire et je
ne peux pas cher de tp avec mes élèves
j'interviens aussi suis en classe de 3e
prépa pro et je ne peux pas s'arrêter je
ne peux pas faire deux sorties
pédagogiques s'est simplement dit aux
personnes concernées de nous trouver des
moines y est propice au travail et les
élèves parce que c'est ça notre objectif
bien qu'on puisse travailler avoir des
moyens voire du financement donc il va
du coup l'aide en souffrance non
l'établissement accueille 250 élèves et
propose quatre filières de formation
chaque année la collectivité
territoriale de martinique lui verse une
dotation de fonctionnement global
d'environ 320 milles euros auxquels il
faut ajouter tête de 95 mille euros de
crédits d'équipement un bûcheur que tous
et murray
remonté